Okay. This question comes from scratch.
Didn't get a chance to eat today and I'm starving all in caps.
How does survivalists get by on like one bug a day?
We don't actually,
the reality of survival situation is you spend most of your time.
Groveling for food.
Everybody thinks you're going to make a bow and arrow out of a piece of thread
and a Bobby pin. It ain't going to happen going hungry.
It's not that big of a deal without water. You're in big trouble without food.
You've got a couple of weeks before you're in real trouble.
So when I'm in a survival situation and I've got no food,
what ends up happening to me is I become really lethargic.
That's the downside of no food. You lose your energy,
but you don't die instantly. Hey, I'm less drought and this is survival.
Okay.
All right. First question comes from just Mickey and he,
or she asks not sure if anyone watched platform on Netflix,
but wouldn't it be healthier to eat the maggots instead of the rotten meat?
Okay. So first of all, full disclosure, I have not seen platform on Netflix.
Actually. I haven't even heard of it,
but I have heard of maggots and I have heard of rotting meat,
and I have eaten both.
There is protein in both eating rotten meat is always the thing that
seems repugnant to everybody in a survival situation.
The reality is that you could eat rotting meat. In fact, many years ago,
most of our cultures all ate rotting meat of some sort.
We have it in many of our different recipes. If you will,
different things that we ate were often rotting, fish, rotting,
foul rotting, red meat. It goes on and on.
The maggots are full of protein and sweetness and sugars.
The real answer to this question, eat them both. All right, next question, Matt.
Borhees asks at real less drought and that's me serious survival question. Open.
Anyone went on a hike today and saw baby bear in a tree.
How close was the mom with question Mark exclamation point question Mark and
exclamation point. So this person is excited. We immediately left the area.
Okay. So an apex predator is like great, white sharks, polar bears,
African lions, Indian tigers,
but a secondary predator is the kind of predator that may eat you.
But it's likely going to be an accidental occasion. So black bears,
cougars, even grizzly bears in the case of a black bear. And for that matter,
in the case of a Cougar, get big, get scary. You can scare them away.
What does that mean? If you come upon a mother and her Cubs,
the majority of the times the mother will be taking off like a shot.
She'll go and she'll hide somewhere. And the Cubs will go up a tree.
How close is the mom?
Bottom line is you don't really want to take the chance because this is the one
time when a black bear is actually very dangerous.
A mother and her Cubs, any other time,
I would work really hard to scare a black bear away.
But when it's a mother and her Cubs, I'm not going to take any chances at all.
So how close was the mother bear to the Cubs? Does it really matter?
It's a mother bear and she's big and probably 340 pounds.
And you're not all right. This next question comes from Steve. Steve Sundell,
Sundell. I'm survivor, man. Right now survivor man. No, it's survivor man.
One word. Get it right. Steve. I'm watching survivor man right now.
And I still have a lingering question for survivalists. Why not?
Just always is, bring a bit lighter with you. You know what? Steve,
I've got the same freaking question.
If you're going to go out in the wilderness,
take a BIC lighter with you every single time. Why not? I agree.
Why not always do it? Okay.
This next question comes with a photograph from frosty. Hey Les,
how do you like my first attempt at spoon making? It's beautiful frosty.
It's a thing of beauty. It's a work of art. And I'll just tell you this story.
When you take a survival class, the first thing you ever make is not a shelter.
It's not a deadfall or a trap or a snare. It's not a bow and arrow.
It's a carved out wooden spoon.
That's the first thing we always teach in survival class is how to carve up a
spoon. Then we go on to trap some animals or gather some wild edibles.
And then the spoon comes in handy.
What we always want to do when we're teaching survival.
Those of us who are survival instructors is get people comfortable with their
hands, with building things, with cutting things, with nature,
but especially with using knives.
It's an incredible how often I'll see people in a survival class with no knife
using skills whatsoever. When you're trying to carve out larger objects.
When you're making dead falls and snares and traps and bows and arrows,
you're much more handy with a knife. All right,
next question comes from Aaron Buck at real estate.
How do you keep the camera batteries charged during your excursions?
I get that question a lot. In fact,
I get a lot of questions about my camera gear and field technique.
And I love those questions because as a filmmaker,
I enjoy sharing my creativity and how I came about it.
And one of the biggest issues in filming survivor, man, and indeed,
and filming my adventures before survivor man was keeping batteries charged.
I spent a year living in the woods and made a documentary called snowshoes and
salted.
And I literally took with me a car battery and a solar panel charged the car
battery during the day and at night with the little adapter charged my camera
batteries. And that got me through a whole year, but it's way different.
Now I can put in a small pack on my hip enough battery
power to last me a week easily. The batteries got small,
they got long lasting.
So I just charge everything up at home and take a bunch in with me.
And it's actually not too heavy anymore.
Steve showing hammer as really hard not to comment on that Steve swing
hammer. How do you prepare for a trip?
Do you binge in the morning before to stay full as long as possible?
Or would that cause problems? Great question.
I don't get this question very often. So I want to answer it. Honestly.
I don't prepare at all.
And the reason why I don't prepare it all is because when I'm going out to film,
I want it to be as real as possible. I know I'm going out.
I know I'm making a film and I know I'm eventually going to go home.
So that nullifies some of the reality of being in a survival situation.
So if I were to also prepare by either gorging on food or slimming down and
trying to make my stomach smaller. So it doesn't hurt as when I'm in the woods,
either way.
Both of those ways in my mind are cheating because when you get lost in the
woods,
you don't prepare the night before thinking I'm going to be lost tomorrow.
And so I needed to have that reality there. So I didn't prepare it all.
I just go in as I go in, if I had a big breakfast that morning. Great.
If I didn't, I did two folks. One asked less,
how do you disinfect your hands in the wild after handling meat?
You're about to cook in this very disinfected society.
I struggle because I believe and agree with science,
that points out that we have a lot of bacteria that is healthy and that we need
now out in the wilderness.
There's even more of that healthy bacteria and even less of the nasty stuff
we're going to get in the grocery store from a shelf.
So I'm a big supporter of getting outside and getting dirty up your fingernails
and being part of the bacteria. That's in nature. So to answer your question,
twofold one, I don't disinfect my hands after handling meat.
I'm about to cook in the wilderness. In fact,
I eat a lot of the wild meat I might catch or come upon raw like
carpaccio or sushi. I don't disinfect my hands. I go with the flow.
I believe that it's actually made me stronger over the years. Chad Harmon asks,
how do you keep from inhaling a ton of smoke when starting fire?
It killed me the few times I tried and I'm a smoker. You kind of don't uh,
there is one trick when I'm doing the fireboat and I'm,
and I'm blowing into the embers and all that you breathe,
you just turned it aside. It's like,
or if I'm down and I'm trying to get a fire going on the ground,
getting started.
Again. It's like,
so.
Absolutely I've gone and choked and sucked in so much smoke.
And meanwhile, you're trying to get your fire going.
So not a good time to stall.
So there's not a really great answer to that question other than turn to the
side and breathe, dude, Christa wants to know at real, less drought,
the following is suddenly driving me nuts.
How does man brush his teeth while out there for seven to 10 days?
Or does he, Oh, you're never going to want to kiss me because I don't, I mean,
I I'll use my finger. Sometimes you can take roots,
like spruce roots and things, and kind of do like a know cleaning of your teeth.
But mostly you're out in the Bush. You ain't cleaning your teeth and yeah,
it is kind of gross at trauma girl. Let's try it.
If you truly only had one single pick at a survival tool, what would you pick?
No matter what the terrain easy answer. And I get this question a lot.
I would have a way to start a fire.
Now. Oh no, no. You've got to have a knife.
No, you need to ask. No yet.
Starting a fire is probably the most difficult thing in a survival situation.
I don't want to rub two sticks together.
Fire is just one of those things that serves so many purposes that I feel that
the best survival skill is knowing how to get a fire going.
So my number one tool, a method to start a fire,
preferably a butane torch lighter style. All right,
hopefully I'm pronouncing this correctly.
Eddie minion at real less drought thoughts on Altoid 10 survival
kits as set and forget items. What would you put in yours?
Interesting question. Don't get me going on survival kits.
Here's the first way I want to answer this question. And let's just say,
if you're going to have a survival kit, do not buy it off the shelf.
Don't do it. Turn away, walk out of the store, come back.
When you're ready to seek out your own items for your survival kit,
pick the things that are high quality, know that you know how to use them,
learn how to use them, put your own kit together.
That's the answer I will always give as far as which is the best survival kit to
have is the one that you make yourself with items you've sourced that you know
how to use, because anything else is just a case of trinkets. You open it up.
Most of it's probably going to be junk.
If it's bought off the shelf and half the time,
you won't even know how to use them. So that's my answer.
Build and keep your own survival kit. All right.
This looks like a serious question.
Mr. Ham tastic wants to know what would you say to someone who wants to take a
year or so and walk the great trail through Canada?
Any advice on planning or anything I could go on for the next hour on giving you
advice on this one, do it don't hesitate. Do it.
Don't think about making money over that period of time or the money you have to
make before you go in or what you're coming out to just do it too.
Many of us do not embark on an adventure because we're
obsessed with or concerned about our at-home lives. Our regular lives.
If you're going out alone or you've got a partner, I say do it.
I spent a year living in the woods and I remember getting a question one time,
how can anyone afford to spend a year living in the woods?
And the crowd went a little silent and I just took a breath.
And I just answered why you can't.
And I got a standing ovation with that answer because the truth is you can't
put these roadblocks in front of you before.
You're about to embark on a great adventure, just embark on it, prepare for it,
write things down, make a lot of lists. There's my pragmatic answer for you.
Write down a lot of lists, get it all focused in and go for it.
Mike Henley asks,
what would you say are the top five edible winter plants in the Temagami region?
For those of you who don't know where Tomago me is to Margaret is in my opinion,
the canoeing Mecca of the world.
There is no place where you can carry out long distance river
to Lake to river canoe trips. Like you can in Tomago Ontario, Canada.
It is stunning there. And not very many people go there. It's not a,
a major national park kind of situation. So you have stunning vistas,
amazing canoeing and not very many people there. It's fantastic.
So it's a great question to ask, but it also leads me down another road,
top five edible winter plants in the Temagami region.
This is a tricky answer because as I like to say in a survival situation,
if you're not on a tropical Island, it's pretty hard to be vegan.
It's pretty hard to be vegetarian. It's almost radically impossible.
So you need to be able to in a winter situation, into mommy, catch game,
like snowshoe Hare, which are easy to catch,
just the same to answer your question, Mikey,
certainly cat tail is always a good winter one because you can,
if you can get through the snow through the ice, down to the bottom,
through the freezing cold water,
the growth for next year is down there and they can be anything from an inch to
six inches long. And it's a beautiful edible. It's kind of like a cucumber.
Other than that, your reduced to a lot of wild teas,
spruce teas, pine tea, Willow tea, Birch tea, boy.
That's about it.
That's hard to gather wild edibles in the winter time in Northern Canada,
but go to, to marketing. You'll love it. Okay.
With the radically esoteric and creative web name of Graham,
he asks, I've got a long trip in the Scottish Highlands in winter.
What should I pack in my car for an emergency? Whoa, great question, Graham.
I can't say this enough that, you know, when I teach about having survival kits,
there's my personal survival kit. There's the group survival kit.
If I'm traveling with people,
I'm also teaching survival kits for in the home home survival kit,
but what's often overlooked and it's so easy is a car survival kit for
emergencies. So really the first thing you need for your car is, you know,
one of those sort of bins, plastic bins with a nice tight fitting lid size wise,
Oh, you know enough that could take 12 bottles of wine or 24 bottles of wine,
but that big,
and in that you pack everything you think you'll need some way to start a fire
way to cook and boil water insulation material,
like a sleeping bag or something like that. It's your car.
You can set up an emergency kit for your car and just leave it and forget that
it's even there.
And that afternoon that you decide to take that shortcut because it's going to
be so cool. Oh, I wonder what that's going to be like over there.
And that's where you get the flat tire.
And you notice that your spares also flat.
You're going to thank me for having a car survival kit.
So what should you pack in it?
Use your own sort of powers of intuition and ingenuity.
What do you think you need if you were stuck with that car on a remote Hill,
in the Highlands of Scotland, Kathleen Stokes,
Phillips asks gonna ask you the silliest question. Well,
actually she's asking it on Capitol, so, gotcha.
I'll ask you the silliest question.
Where do you find toilet paper to go poo LOL,
depending on where you are.
Usually the best toilet paper in the woods is MOS. Most of the Moscow vine,
if not, all of it is not poisonous to the touch leaves are tricky.
You do not want to wipe your butt with poison Oak.
You do not want to wipe your butt with poison Ivy.
You do not want to wipe your butt with a cactus plant.
So find a MOS best toilet paper. In fact, my favorite kind of boss,
which sadly for the lower 48, you can't really get,
but up in the boreal forest, there's a mosque called Spagna Moss.
And for years it was actually used by indigenous cultures as their diapers,
as their toilet paper, it has antiseptic qualities to it.
It's my favorite paper. It's soft and it's good,
whether it's moist or dry and that's where I should stop there.
Or it's going to become too much information. Jolana Kia.
I like that name at Jolana Kia asks if perfect balance,
isn't part of your survivalist skillset.
How are you going to make it past your seventies?
Good point you might not do so well.
And that's why I still to this day and for the sake of a guy with a back that is
beaten up by, by carrying canoes, heavy packs and playing hockey.
I still do yoga every single day because balance is important.
Something that's overlooked in a survival situation is one of the key components
of whether or not you will survive. Something is actually your fitness level.
And so even for hardcore wilderness survival,
my yoga helps me a lot.
When I got a scale that Rocky area climb through that go through that swamp
balance is really important.
So how are you going to make it past your seventies without balance with
difficulty, everyone? Thank you so much for the questions.
Obviously some of them were silly and some of them were serious and I like
approaching survival that way anyway, because the thing is you got to laugh.
If you're in a survival situation,
remember there is only one thing you want to do go home.
You don't want to get to the other end of a survival situation and go, Oh,
I wish I'd made a better A-frame shelter, man. I wish I had tan to hide.
Now you want to go home in a survival situation.
So humor is important to keep your spirits alive.
I'm really grateful for these questions. They've been great.
I'm Les Stroud and this has been survival support.